slaying zombies directing movies and
looking Fab Danny has all grown up and
still showing up forever and ever
watching the 1993 film Hocus Pocus is a
requisite on Halloween not only is the
movie full of spooky fun but it also has
plenty of heart one of the film's most
endearing characters is Dany portrayed
by Thora Birch the little sister of Max
Denison
oh Danny
I scared you I scared you
in the film Max begrudgingly goes
trick-or-treating with his sister and
they end up at the Sanderson sisters
home where complete chaos ensues with
the help of the child turned black cat
Thackery Binks the zombie Billy
butcherson and Max's Crush Allison the
siblings managed to escape their
encounter with the witches unscathed
during an October 2018 Interview With
People magazine the film's director
Kenny Ortega briefly spoke about Thora
burch's performance as Danny and
couldn't stop gushing about her
performance
Thora Birch one of the brightest young
children to this day that I've ever
worked with I mean she was so ahead of
the class Birch also discussed her
experience working on Hocus Pocus while
speaking to access in October 2018 Burch
shared that she understood the
significance of acting alongside Bette
Midler
I know I was so excited I mean working
with her was like working with like a an
idol of yours after Hocus Pocus
premiered Thora Birch appeared in a
number of notable films including now
and then American Beauty and Ghost World
in 2019 the actor began playing Mary on
the hit AMC show The Walking Dead though
as fans are aware her character was
relegated entirely to the show's 10th
season while speaking to KTLA 5 in
October 2019 Birch revealed that she was
not familiar with The Walking Dead prior
to joining the series cast I hadn't
watched the show before I started season
10 but I went down the rabbit hole
immediately and started like jamming the
the seasons the actor then revealed that
she found it difficult to shoot the
series due to the Atlanta heat where the
show is filmed but found the experience
rewarding nonetheless it's a blast
because you get to do so many types of
things that normally you don't do since
her Walking Dead stint Thora Birch has
only appeared in two subsequent roles
the lead in Oklahoma tornado film 13
minutes and as the star of narrative
podcast over leaper she's currently
slated to appear in a TV movie based on
the real life story of Gabby potito
which she's also directing as well as
the Wednesday Adams TV series Wednesday
that said Birch left Wednesday Midway
into its production since she remains
credited on six episodes of the series
online however it's possible that the
show's producers will indeed make use of
some of what Birch filmed during her
time on set but even if she doesn't show
up in Wednesday you can always relive
her early career defining performance as
Danny Dennison in Hocus Pocus
it's been great fun but I I guess I
better be going oh stay for supper